Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update during the latest Weekend Update
for destiny Bungie responded to an
accusation that they're ignoring Xbox
users a fan asked will you guys give a
nod to your Xbox fan base or just keep
ignoring them Bungie community manager
David dig responded with who's ignoring
you we're right here making a game we
hope you'll love we're listening to your
questions and answering the ones we can
if you're a gamer who wants to play a
bungie game you're very much on our mind
every day on that's sweet the fans
question is likely derived from the fact
that destiny was featured at Sony's
PlayStation 4 announcement in February's
2013 and then again at Sony's e3
briefing later that year furthermore
sony has teamed up with bungie for a new
ps4 commercial and perhaps most
importantly the destiny beta is coming
this summer first to PlayStation 3 and 4
Bungie of course is famous for the Halo
games which were originally released
exclusively for Xbox consoles so this
seeming change of loyalty is notable
however timed exclusivity for specific
platform is nothing new with
multi-platform games just look at all
the call of duty DLC for the last
generation that came first to xbox 360
it's less about what the developers
prefer as a platform and more about the
business side of things we've got a
bunch of new gameplay footage for
destiny up on the site right now as well
as a hefty preview so be sure to check
that out and stay tuned to gamespot com
all this week for continuing destiny
coverage